[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another episode of outdoor
boys YouTube channel and it's finally
cooled down enough where I can stand to
be outside forging and I'm excited that
all summer to think about what I want to
do it we've got some great projects
planned this winter and for those of you
who follow my channel pretty religiously
you might have noticed that I got a new
forge stand so let me show you the new
forged stand I've got upside-down
aluminum diamond plate on the surface
aluminum won't rust obviously and it'll
prevent it from burning when hot coals
fall out and then I've got the joints
notched and so you can see here where I
inserted the pieces together made a lot
stronger used exterior deck screws
instead of nails which is you know
another real basic thing and then I've
got lots of these cross members here the
old design I had a shelf on the bottom
which I thought I'd use for storage I
never used it and the lack of cross
support just made it really wobbly
especially over time the more I used it
this one is really rock-solid hopefully
this will work a lot better I'm really
excited to give it a go so right here
you can see I've got the shop vac
blowing air into a perforated tube with
a bunch of pea gravel in it and this is
the basic Forge that I've been using for
the last number of years if you want to
see a video on how to build this up in a
link in the description but for my first
forging project of the year I've got
something special planned for you guys I
am going to turn this old pickaxe into a
double bitted battle-ax
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just get me a long project
[Music]
well I was hoping to make more progress
before it was time to quit for the day
but it is what it is I'm a little bit
slower a little bit more out of shape
than I was at the beginning of the
summer but we'll go ahead and put this
up right now and pick it up just a
little bit
what we really need to do is start
working on this edge pounding the metal
here along this side to gradually draw
it out so that its beginnings of an edge
and then I need to shape this profile
but we'll kind of see how it goes
[Music]
you having fun with Daddy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well that turned out pretty darn well
I'm happy with what I got so far
but the real challenge is about to begin
because I've got to stick this part in
the Forge and hold it by this part and
then if I bend it down it's gonna be
awfully close I I may not be able to do
this without burning my hands I may need
to invest in a pair of welders gloves my
sweet children gave me they're cold and
I'm gonna try to do some foraging today
and finish up the second half of this
pickaxe but we'll see how it goes
I'm kind of tired and starting
[Music]
[Music]
well guys they got the rough shape done
and I'm pretty happy with how it turned
out but there's definitely some things I
would do differently let me show you
remember how I used that angle grinder
to groove the the pickaxe I did that to
encourage it to fold in a specific
location but it didn't really work and
in the end it caused this ugly little
aisle defect in there but it's not
structural it's you know just
superficial I thought it would close up
when bending and the other side did but
this one didn't and it just it just
wasn't worth it well I was really
worried about getting everything
symmetrical and it actually turned out
pretty well the one problem I had is
when I first folded the second part of
the pickaxe I bent half an inch further
from the I then the other side did and
so I had to correct for that and that
was a lot of work and in the end it
caused this point to be about a little
less than a half of an inch shorter but
I fixed it all except for this part and
I'll just use the angle grinder to even
that up alright guys now it's time to
bust out the angle grinder put an edge
on this thing clean it up a little bit
and even the two tines out alright got
to save that little piece for later
that'll be important
[Music]
I don't know what type of steel this is
unless you know what type of steel
you're working with you don't know how
to properly heat treat it what you
should quench it in whether or not you
need to anneal it what temperature you
need to get it at each steel and each
Holloway is different so you know it's
just kind of hitting in the dark so
that's where this little extra piece of
steel comes in I think I need a water
quench this this project if I'm wrong
it'll make it too brittle so I'm gonna
test it out on this little tiny piece
here and if this little piece shatters
after I water quench it then I know I
probably need to oil quench
well we got the fire roaring hot but a
little too hot it was like burning my
forehead just even mess with stuff with
the Tong so I spread it out turn off the
fan let it cool down a bit because I
want a nice gentle fire for the heat
treating process don't want to burn the
edges melt anything and I am going to
start by taking this a little bit of
steel in there we're gonna heat it up
we're going to water quench it and see
what happens
then shat or after I hit it about six
times with the four pound sledge so
pretty tough not too brittle but I think
I'm gonna want to anneal it so this is
probably somewhere around 1060 1070 ish
steel and I'm gonna win a water quench
it and then bake it in the oven for a
while to soften about up a bit
well getting the whole axe had
consistently heated was a real challenge
I had to make a horseshoe-shaped bed of
coals and really tend it and tweak it to
get it cherry red as evenly as possible
to anneal the axe head I'm gonna put it
in the oven at 450 degrees for about an
hour so we'll see how that goes
and it looks like my lovely wife has
made pasta for dinner thank you babe all
right well you ended up baking this
thing in the oven for about an hour and
a half and I don't see any cracks or
warps and so we're just gonna go ahead
and knock the slag off it polish it up a
little bit put an edge on it
[Applause]
not quite shave with it sharp but pretty
darn good the way these pickaxe eyes are
made they're designed so that you feed
the handle from the bottom down instead
of from the bottom up like you would an
axe handle so what it means is the
handle has to be smaller than the bottom
of the eye which is approximately two
inches by three inches and then what you
make is at the top of the handle you
make it flare out so that it jams in
here and doesn't feed all the way
through the eye
[Music]
so far so good but we'll pick this up
again tomorrow it's a crisp fall morning
we're gonna keep working on this axe
handle I'm gonna grind out the head and
just kind of clean up the head a little
bit yeah keep going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's witnessing a lot of curious how
much this thing weighs that is eight
pounds oh that is beastly look at that
look yeah
oh you can absolutely do some damage
with it it's kind of a goofy design and
just kind of a fun fun thing so I have
no idea how effective of an actual axis
is so we better go find out let's go
chop some crap all right guys let me
give you a little bit of a close-up here
good-looking little axe well I have some
serious questions about the
functionality of this axe but you gotta
admit it looks awesome
[Music]
okay maybe it's not so bad
oh well that is a lot of work so I think
this is a very utilitarian battle-ax no
was it a lot of fun to make it swing yes
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
and I hope to take away from this is
that this is easy to do you don't need a
lot of equipment you don't need years of
practice just try something you know
going out there dry blacksmithing try
making axes and restoring stuff it's fun
and you don't have to impress anyone
other than yourself so enjoy yourself
enjoy these videos and remember we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
and we have a whole playlist dedicated
to forging and tool restoration videos
I'll put a link in the description so
thanks for watching don't forget to
click Subscribe have a great day Oh